my name is Ben cash or and I am the
faculty director for the
of box Fellows program and I'm really
delighted to welcome you here to our
second of five events on leadership the
Flex scholarship is hosting the first
one was a month a half ago with
leadership in the environment but today
is on corporate social responsibility
and we will be having in - in the spring
term when on human rights in the
environment at the law school and went
on public health of the School of Public
Health in addition as part of our Fox
reunion in India we're having a very
special session on leadership on me in
the BRICS countries as well you're all
working on that as well so with that
might I want to give you a couple just a
couple of words on the Fox fellowship
and why we're here today and then turn
it over to my colleague Mary insert out
who'll introduce our guest speaker jerry
moon so the reason why we're here and
what the flex scholarship is hosting
this event
which i must reinforce his co-sponsored
by the center for business in the
environment and yale which was an
organization that houses with a School
of Management and the Yale School of
Forestry and environmental studies
together to think properly about how we
may draw on the scholarship and practice
of business noubar
to make a difference in the world um the
reason why we're here is that 26 years
ago Joseph Fox who was a graduate of
Yale College in the 1930s when he
retired at the age of 75 decided to give
back back to the Yale community by
creating a fellowship Devon generate new
understandings among citizens the
universities and countries around the
world to address some of the most
important and critical challenge of
station our planet we like to joke that
the initial problem was the Cold War and
when year after the fellowship was
created the Cold War ended so we take
responsibility for that impact on other
environmental crises and CSR challenges
um but part of the vision that Jill
flocks and his family his wife Allison
had was to generate the leaders of
tomorrow those students scholars who
didn't just have an interest in the
scholarship and the important work
they're doing across environment health
security development so on but also in
the practice of improving the world
around problems in ways that generates
collaborative solutions is the reason
for this fellowship linking those two
together and today now we have 25 years
18 international partners we added five
last year including the you know the
Copenhagen or the Copenhagen Business
School and hence that Jeremy is from one
of our departments and we're really
grateful to be here so what I want to
emphasize now and I hope you can help us
build is that we want to make sure that
within Yale but the range of students
who might want to take this fellowship
to Copenhagen to Singapore to South
Africa are aware of it I understand why
it's important and that thinking
therefore making applications that are
due when I come
and this is being recorded this very
event right now so we can email the heck
out of this talk to those like my
electronic students all right so with
that I want to turn over the
introductions to my colleague Mary Kirk
out
who is an expert in corporations and
their environmental stewardship and has
in fact the founding scholar in the
field of industrial ecology which is now
an internationally recognized approach
for integrating understanding how
corporations interact
thank you Ben it's an honor to be here
and to learn a little bit more about the
Fox Fellowship and I've enjoyed watching
you lead the program and now I have a
little bit better sense of how it all
began my most important duty today is to
welcome you and also to welcome our
distinguished guest speaker professor
Jeremy moon Jeremy is the Velux
professor of corporate sustainability at
the Copenhagen Business School and he
got to Copenhagen Business School in
2014 prior to that since 2002 he was at
the International Centre for corporate
social responsibility at the University
of Nottingham
did I say that right not a oh good good
okay oh and also deputy Dean of the
Nottingham University business center
Jeremy brings a political scientists
background and view to the study of of
corporate sustainable both corporate
sustainability and corporate social
responsibility a little bit of business
and politics in there and looks at
questions from a conceptual evaluative
organizational and comparative views so
we'll get a great deal out of your
insights on leadership with those lenses
and I would say that Jeremy's central
question is how does business contribute
to the way we are governed and at dinner
last
night I learned that you have a both a
deep and broad view of these questions
so this will also be very interesting
for our audience let me take a
commercial word here for a moment
Jeremy is the co-author Jeremy is the
author of a book that many people in
this audience have read called the very
short introduction to corporate social
responsibility that was published by
Oxford University Press in 2014 now the
commercial message is that the CSR
literature has sprawled a great deal and
Jeremy somehow took it upon himself to
rein it back in and write this very
short introduction and somehow make it
all make sense so I was delighted to
read that when been recommended to me a
year ago and now we have many others who
have have discovered the book as well so
very glad to have you here I I note that
you've also published a lot of work on
Asia a area of interest for me including
CSR in China which I managed to get
through last night so we're just very
pleased to hear you and also to engage
in dialogue with you so I'm gonna guess
the journey when we talk about 40 45
minutes or so and then we'll definitely
have time for Q&A and then we'll also
have time for a little nourishment when
that's all done so thank you and welcome
Jeremy thank you thank you very much I
hope that I can speak without the
microphone is that working for you yes
it is very good thank you for the kind
introduction and thank you also for
coming especially those who have already
suffered the book I really had by I'm
very pleased to be here for a number of
reasons not being seen New Haven before
I've not been to Yale before I knew
about New Haven because I read a book
called who governs which when I was a
student which has written I think of the
late fifties if I remember rightly by
Dahl who it was a bit of a hero of mine
when I was a student
not least his work on democracy but he
also had interests in forms of business
that were socially responsible and ways
of making markets acceptable to
democracy and I've office also followed
the work more recent it should be said
if there's been cash or so it's a double
pleasure to be here and it's a triple
pleasure to address this topic because
unbeknownst to you perhaps I've not
actually written about CSR and
leadership before but I was intrigued by
the challenge I have written about
leadership before a book in which acting
came out in the mid not only mid-90s
about Margaret Thatcher quite tell the
theme of Fletcher's leadership and that
of CSR will connect I'm not quite sure
but with although we may be able to come
back to that so first of all the topic
it's a tricky one leadership's a bit of
a teaser what is it is it really about
the people well
MacGregor burns burns says no it's about
processes and deemed a voter who had
been a Dean turned the berkeley business
called the haskell so sort of similar
thing about csr it's a great idea but
we're not really sure what it is both of
them could be described as essentially
contested but frankly so are most
important things justice democracy
liberty so let's not shy away just
because these are difficult concepts
this is the structure that the the talk
will take if there are points where you
find when I say perplexing do to put
your hand up or just in to ask me but I
will also have a break for questions
about two-thirds of the way through the
short story is CSR possibly was always
difficult but rather much more easy than
it is today and in some ways the
leadership challenge is all the greater
and in fact the imperatives
for leadership accordingly are greater
I'm just posing these questions because
you might ponder these during my remarks
we might come back to them at the end of
course you may have your own questions
to what extent or if at all does csr
bring distinctive challenges for
leadership or are the leadership
challenges basically all the same
difficult who should be responsible for
CSR leadership once upon a time that
might have been a relatively easy
question to answer but perhaps less so
now for reasons you'll see shortly
what's the nature of the challenges is
it about issues is it about ways in
which corporations engage and finally
even if we can identify some leadership
agendas and some reasons for having
leaders and possibly identifying who
they should be how does leadership
actually achieved so that those will be
my concluding remarks first of all I
guess just to stress the importance CSR
is important for society the
significance of corporations in some
ways has always been great but I think
yet greater fairly obviously the
positive and negative externalities are
multiplied given the increasing growth
and reach the corporations have and
their contributions to governance
sometimes these contributions to
governance are harder to see but lie
underneath smoke-filled rooms that I
think Dahl talked about at one point is
one one model but obviously we're
looking for different sorts of models in
which the corporations aren't accused of
corrupting the system or exploiting
their their their advantages
corporations have been very significant
in globalization but of course then have
encountered a number of challenges
around around the themes of CSR but of
course there are opportunities which
we'll touch on and of course we live in
an age where questions are being asked
about globalization and its merits for
society people for workers
but of course then what's the role of
corporations in the context of these
challenges to globalization and the
associated associated agendas to obvious
associated agendas our taxation and
mechanisms for addressing environmental
issues particularly climate change but
it's also important for business and
again I think this shouldn't be
overlooked
I mean business does rely on certainly
climactic and other environmental
conditions access to natural resources
most obviously it also relies on social
conditions just trying to think of an
adage which yeah that's right when a
company and I studied in the 1980s was
asked why it was making these corporate
social responsibility investments it was
saying that healthy and if they were
investing in slum areas healthy back
streets make for healthy wealthy high
streets so there's a sort of these
people saw a link between the social
conditions for business but I think more
we could stretch that a little bit and
talk about the issues of trust in
markets in the institutions that govern
markets and in companies themselves and
of course corporate social
responsibility as it has emerged
particularly in the last decade or two
has provided a an opportunity for
collective action in the absence of
Leviathan
when hitherto corporate social
responsibility tended to be the work of
individual companies and accordingly I
would say you don't need to be a CSR
enthusiast to observe that the agenda
status of this term has changed
dramatically sadly people keep going
around saying CSR which if you're from
China could mean China South railways
but for the most part people know what
CSR means and it this ft leader writer
of quoted here who says and I it's an
idea whose time has come and he was a he
was quite a sceptic about the phenomenon
reporting data is one way of getting at
how companies see it as important and
within companies
CSR is moved if you like from the
margins the sort of social worker type
at the end of the corridor to occupy and
preoccupy folks in supply marketing
governance and so forth and I think of
course the other thing is that CSR is a
term which is familiar to those who
criticize and try and regulate companies
from civil society and society at large
but what the heck is it it's obviously a
bundle of things and different elements
of it gets stressed in different
circumstances which goes back to our
opening problem and of course
consultants and academics don't help
because they're always trying to come up
with a conceptualization which
distinguishes them from the others they
get more citations or more business
depending on or maybe both in the case
of some academics if the moment will
remain nameless in most general term I
mean it's defined in very many different
ways my friend dark matter and I decided
to define it like this and I think the
significance is a couple of points of
significance policies and practices of
corporations this is irrespective of
what laws and governments require of
them in our view that was a different
issue companies should be responsible
notwithstanding whatever structures or
motivates that but nonetheless a lot of
discretion still lies with the
corporation we don't even define the the
issues of the agendas wider societal
good and for us that's as defined by the
society there's an assumption of
responsiveness here but you could find
that wholly unsatisfactory
it could be limits to anything so you
might know in your quest for insight
wisdom and understanding press further
and say well who has these two whom
other companies responsible than what
are they so let's just unpick these
questions a little bit first of all who
has the responsibilities well the word
corporate or corporation features in the
acronym and quite rightly too in
corporations manifestly
have different responsibilities and
special ones beyond those which rest on
other businesses they get a lot of
privileges and they also that them the
liabilities of shareholders are
suspended which in itself is a privilege
for the shareholders but corporations
themselves depending on the jurisdiction
also have a lot of privileges but the
term has been applied business wide and
I think rightly so because of because
otherwise we simply have organizations
with market power without
responsibilities so far so good you
might say but of course CSR is no longer
governed by corporations alone or even
businesses alone and there's been a
shift and my colleagues Russia and
tobacco and I conceptualized this as a
shift from the complete organization of
CSR within a corporation to its partial
organization so that the corporations
are just one of several actors who
actually governs CSR and character
characteristically the complete
organization of CSR was when a
corporation decided to make a
philanthropic gesture it decided to whom
the money went
how much on what occasion and so forth
but the part the partial organization
means that these standards norms
reporting mechanisms which corporations
are expected to use in their CSR are
actually devised evaluated and monitored
by others not only by the corporation's
themselves so here a multiplication if
you like with the leadership challenge
to illustrate this I'm not usually very
good at diagrams
these are easy ones relatively for me so
we start off with the corporate centered
CSR CSR with the corporation at the
centre Nestle has its business
principles it decides what those are
Unilever has its sustainable agriculture
guidelines again it would decide what
they are probably actually in
consultation with others but let's
bracket that for the moment
and then we have what you might call
business centered rather than corporate
centered CSR and here businesses get
together and form associations and
networks to agree standards to agree
norms it's already then it's becoming an
association of activity and I'll give
you some examples of those yet more
partial if you like civil society
organizations join the game partnerships
with stewardship councils ethical
trading initiatives in various countries
so you see how the Corporations complete
organization CSR is thinning to put it
mildly and then even though of course
the multi-stakeholder era which involves
international governmental organisations
and even of course corporations and
governments whereby governments are
involved in specifying what's socially
responsible I've given you examples of
the dodd-frank act set of exceptions
particularly pertaining to extractive
industries as one that's interested me
various corruption acts or reporting
acts we've come back to discuss these
and the significance for CSR what what I
wanted to point out here though is that
these bring for other different
relationships with government then again
that doll might have imagined in his in
his work in particular the who governs
which might have been reporting or quiet
words on the side or some campaigning
this is rather different it's it's
collective you know collective action in
collaboration but transparency must be
must be observed
so of course you could even go further
there are others who are involved in the
organisation of CSR who have
expectations and leverage and sometimes
they bring these to bear in the way
corporations think about their CSR
investors and the obviously through SR I
investment but even now investors who
don't label
selves as ethical or sr I might be
concerned about social and environmental
risk which is quite often our mainstream
investors frame these things customers
on whose behalf systems have been
devised to hold companies more
accountable and to enable customers to
identify the different few out
responsibility characteristics of the
goods they and services they buy well
let's move to the second question to
whom our corporations responsible so a
bit of a moot point and a fairly
standard answer is the answer of Edie
Freeman the stakeholders this is of
course paradoxical because Freeman I
should say is a friend of mine but he's
quite skeptical about CSI what's to
collect corporate stakeholder
responsibility and all sorts of things
like this but notwithstanding his
anxieties about the term of course CSR
academics and practitioners and
companies in the way they specify their
policies use the fruit the stakeholder
model and you've probably familiar with
these sorts of charts this actually came
from his 1984 book and the contrast of
courses with what he called the
traditional management model it seems to
me that there are there are problems
here and there are key things missing
non organizational stakeholders are
underestimated society it's in vain but
one and quite what you do with the
environment well you know more about
that than I do but you know it's
obviously a problem and the stakeholder
model really rather unsatisfactory from
this this from this respect it always
seems to me that government is
misspecified
to see government and say stakeholder
just like a supplier or a consumer seems
to miss so with the core attributes of
governments the capacity to make rules
and coerce seems to me to us distinguish
them okay they can't and can sometimes
be customers or even suppliers but
nonetheless they seem to be of a
different kind
and then moving to what are the
responsibilities I guess one of the
other famous contributors here is
another American scholar Archie Carroll
and he specifies four sorts of
responsibilities economic legal ethical
and philanthropic sometimes he's changed
the word philanthropic and sometimes
called it citizenship he seems now to be
back with with philanthropic and we have
Archie's famous pyramid and the
distinguishing definitions on the right
hand side again this will be familiar to
many of you again it seems to me that
there are there are bits missing here
the two fairly obvious ones are market
responsibility what responsibilities do
companies hold to their competitors
suppliers customers and governance
responsibilities he does specify of
course that companies one responsibility
is what the law requires but that's very
much a sort of regulation taking idea he
doesn't think about the way corporations
contribute to or make governance so I
would say that's something that would
also need to be included but of course
the who to whom and the wats are not
constant they're highly contextual
according to sectors or individual
companies indeed and their impact
sectors countries and of course very
dynamic and I just want to give some
illustration of this again to anticipate
this the way that the challenges for
leaders are changing so my way of
thinking about this is my latest the
latest iteration is to look at think
about issues modes and rationalizations
just enable us to think what's what's
changing and what's comparative so the
issues from industrial to
post-industrial on the industrial side
concerns about working conditions
pollution postings industrial
expectations for corporations to think
about diversity work home balance
and so forth from charity to governance
and that's the idea of giving some money
compared to being involved in thinking
about the circumstances of people's
lives even to the extent of human human
rights from a firm in a community
perspective to firm and value chains
companies are being asked to take a lot
of responsibility for their value chains
but they're not even our people not
people we employ night Nike was
challenged in the 1980s for the way it's
a in Indonesian suppliers were employing
people no Nike was employing people and
that's how many years ago that is 30 30
plus years these are quite dramatic
changes Nike in the end took that quite
seriously it's taken other companies an
awful long time to think about how to be
responsible for their value chains and
it's very very difficult particularly in
the soccer ball industry going beyond
the first tier of supply because there's
so much home working for example from
negative externalities do no harm to
conditions for business and society how
can we make the world better if you like
and then from the national to the
multinational international and global
but you could also think about how do we
do it and how much that's changed and
you'll forgive this sexist reference of
the first up but this was at what I
observed when I first started studying
CSR in the nearly said 1880s 1980s that
quite often it was the Chairman's wife
who made decisions about which charities
to support moving on companies then
develop foundations which may have been
professionalized in time to make these
allocations to monitor the impacts of
their philanthropy and then of course
partnerships use of social
entrepreneurship standards codes and so
on even down to the bottom line we're
going back to my previous point really
about partial organization whereby the
mode of CSR is one in which corporations
are engaged with other others if you
like mutual regulation in
Association social regulation in MSI's
and government regulation in the soft
rules about reporting for example so
again quite quite an agenda for it for
leaders even in contrast to ten or
twenty years ago and then
rationalizations I'm not quite sure
whether you'll be able to read all that
from where you're standing I'm not
supposed to move actually otherwise the
camera are going to be angry but so I'll
just just you'll get these slides if you
want them later on but I picked out some
rationalizations at five or six and
these all but one the quotes I give to
support the rationalizations were from
the 19th century but we can identify
their 20th late 20th century versions so
just coming down the left-hand side for
rational number one the social
responsibility of businesses to create
wealth and that's a Friedman Milton
Friedman's famous essay 1917 even though
is I think a railway magnate from this
country who came up with the quote I
give on the right number to the social
responsibility of business is to use
wealth for social ends obviously
Carnegie the the greatest authority on
this all the most inspiring author on it
with his have now forgotten more than
the book was called but this of course
is the Bill Gates Foundation model make
a lot of money and then you use it for
by one means or another and then you use
it for social ends third business should
be a vehicle for social responsibility
this was Rockefeller slightly different
interpretation the idea of running a
business enables people to work to earn
to develop and I would say you might
associate this with Anita Roddick in the
body shop that in her case creating a
business was in a means of enhancing
animal rights agendas a means of
enhancing international development
agendas CSR legitimize this business to
society and government this actually is
an author writing about late 19th
century English business leaders and I
think a lot of the companies that go
abroad use CSR as a means of legitimate
themselves in strange places if you like
and I would say it's also true of the
Tata company which adopted an idea
in the late 19th early 20th century that
which comes from the Parsee tradition
you need to be so particularly their
sociable in a land where you're a
stranger csr is a vehicle for wealth
creation the author here I quote is
Robert Owen one of the people associated
the formation of the co-operative
movement and founded model villages more
successfully in Britain and in America
as I understand it but this of course is
portering kramer in a nutshell csr is a
vehicle for wealth creation and then
finally this is of the do one twentieth
century quote I used CSR as a form of
government governance this is from
Etzioni of famous communitarian scholar
and commentator though the quote
actually as I recall was from the late
1970s CSR is a form of governance you
might associate this with the way that
corporations use ruggers guidelines on
on human rights so CSR is very important
but it's contextual it's dynamic
there are uncertain relationships as a
result with with and between the
business of profit-making and fitting in
with regulation being relevant being
regulated and one of my favorite
business leaders working in
controversial companies Sir Mark moody
Stuart would say there's no rulebook for
this at all so I suppose any module
which of course which offers to teach
you about CSR and leadership might might
be a little bit a little bit skeptical
of might even be skeptical about
somebody giving a talk on the subject
because there's no rulebook so that's my
short tour of corporate social
responsibility in which I've tried to
set up and give you a sense of the
challenges that leaders face because
lean leadership here requires dealing
with the these dynamics these different
relationships DIF
to genders and the playing off of
different rationalizations so before I
come then to look more closely at the
leadership challenge I pause and give
you a moment if there's any points of
clarification or criticism of my short
tour whilst you're doing that I'll take
on
no I didn't say anything especially
about that okay I guess it's not because
I don't think it's important I guess
from in my mind it would be going back
to the rationalizations business social
responsibility of businesses to use
wealth for social social sorry the
Rockefeller one business should be a
vehicle for social responsibility and
these are Rockefellers words I'm sorry
that you probably can't read them the
help that nourishes civilization is the
investment of effort or time or money to
the power of employing people at a
remunerative wage remunerative wage so
this was part of the Rockefeller idea at
least and I think a number of I mean a
number of companies that I've observed
in the United Kingdom have often been
campaigning for a minimum wage and often
for it to be higher because they prefer
a level playing field on these sorts of
things but in other countries where
those there's no hope of that sort of
regulation I think men that is a
responsibility and it's one that's been
addressed by such initiatives as the
ethical trading initiative which is a
British based initiative but there were
versions in Norway and Denmark so that
those that would be very very much as
part of their agenda and I think also
some of the Fairtrade initiatives are
around remuneration so I think it's not
what it's absent but did you have a
particular point that you wanted to make
about it other than I ignoring it
oh I beg your pardon
yeah no I did also refer to the word
taxation when I was talking about some
of these current contemporary genders
particularly the sort of questioning of
globalization because I think one quite
reasonably one of the criticisms of
globalization has been the ease with
which corporations play games with where
they report their tech report their
taxes and I understand that's an issue
here it certainly is in in parts of
Europe and I mean there have been some
attempts by regulators to address this
as you probably know the Tobin tax was
waved around the European Commission has
addressed it but I think probably given
up there have been CSR initiatives
around this and the one I was slightly
involved in in the United Kingdom is at
nearly a decade ago and I've I fear not
much has changed the main British
Business Association called business in
the community which is devoted to CSR
has done work on this I'm sure sorry I'm
not able to tell you how its impacted on
the how their member companies behave
yeah
well I think this now now there's an
assumption that it's the value chain is
where the responsibility is held and
that goes for the provenance of Natural
Resources as well as the treatment of
people at that end of the value chain
but I think also a lot of companies are
taking very seriously the other end of
the value chain so a variety of examples
so hewlett-packard will give advice on
reuse or recycling or giving back every
redundant equipment Unilever is gives it
a lot of advice on the amount of
detergent you need mats water rather
that you need to mix with a certain
amount of detergent to clean your
clothes and they've even gone to sort of
mass campaigning in parts of Southeast
Asia because unfortunately people who
did the washing forgive the sexist
remark often the women weren't able
necessary to read or understand the
instructions about actually you don't
need so much water with this detergent
that's the whole point
so there's but there's also concern with
that that that ends and of course a lot
of companies have got interested in
cradle to cradle opportunities frankly
which for many companies are not very
plausible because this their
contribution so narrow it's a value
chains but nonetheless and how to have
to use waste and my colleagues an expert
on this and talks about Danish relation
danish examples about how our end of you
know an end of life resources can be a
beginning of life for another company so
i'd say that if that's what you mean
that the responsibility outside the
company itself to other societies but
also to different ends of the value
chain I think those are being taken
seriously but again is there something
you're trying to push me on which I've
missed
but since ever together then what
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah no sorry I missed the
first time around and of course a lot of
the International agendas are from home
countries of those corporations and and
and quite often it's hard to engage so
I've been looking quite closely at the
poster on the plaza initiatives where
companies are trying to engage with
Bangladeshi trade unions for example on
thinking about conditions of work in
ensuring them and of course Bangladeshi
trade unions are an oppressed category
really notwithstanding the efforts that
American and European governments have
made to sway the Bangladeshi government
otherwise so with best will in the world
it's quite hard to seriously engage with
those trade unionists in the way that
they might do in Washington or London so
I think I think there are difficulties
and of course CSR has often been called
a southern imperialist venture that to
make exploitation acceptable one way or
another and some African leaders have
pointed out that CSR if it is going to
raise the wages of African workers is
actually doing them a disservice because
it's argued I'm not saying this but a
cheap labor is their competitive edge
and if the wages they go up the business
might may as well go back to Australia
Britain or America again a topical thing
ok so I turn then to the leadership
challenges which would be rather a
shorter presentation and then we can
come back to these and related questions
so I mean
leadership is obviously always called
for at the very time when it's most
difficult and that's almost by
definition the wick wicked problems that
are associated particularly them some of
the environmental challenges that
companies face a lot of the
uncertainties were not about trade-offs
the claims anticipated claims of
stakeholders the next moves of
competitors civil society and regulators
and the fact that solutions won't just
happen market or developmental or
technological logics for the most part
don't for themselves so solve these
sorts of problems moreover in retrospect
we see that leadership has been critical
in csr in some of the companies which we
must associate with responsible business
there have been long-run commitment by
people who have new personal values of
social responsibility you could name
your own companies who would fit that
bill but also point to quite often where
companies have had some sort of renewal
sometimes only short term sometimes
longer term that's been associated with
a leadership leadership move a famous
one on the responsibility side is Ray
Anderson and his company interfaced
American carpet company which had quite
a dramatic change well-publicized
example was I think about eight years
ago when Walmart announced that it was
going to I think I forget entirely the
details Go Go Green and but this again
was associated by with Lee Scott then
CEO there's a some word missing there
interestingly these sometimes reflect
and they reflect interestingly
intergenerational moments and you might
think it's a bit perverse quite often
these these Damascus Road experiences
are associated with the birth of a child
or a grandchild and this idea the sort
of intergenerational moment may awaken
for how long there is some of these
leaders but also of course lack of
leadership in its absence
it makes for corporate social
irresponsibility and again you've
probably got your own examples so let's
not dwell there and I think one of the
things that I've found in the research
on CSR and leadership is that this sort
of leadership needs to and can reflect
both transformational and transactional
elements these are often thought to be
sort of antithetical to each other
transformational is visionary resetting
frameworks bringing new norms
transactional negotiated iterative
working within established frameworks
rather than recreating them but groups
have I missed one no yeah so the
transformational leadership very very
apparent that corporations need to bring
if you like new perspectives on their
companies need to site their companies
in new institutional contexts and quite
often this involves wholesale rethinking
over company's own impacts its products
its services and some of the researchers
identified intellectual curiosity as a
key factor in the in the leaders who
seem to have a transformational effect
on their companies why well to
understand the complexities of the
circumstances again there's no there's
no rulebook here these these
complexities need to be understood and
very much so at a individual company
level rather than in general terms but
also a curiosity about the past how did
we get here what sort of mod business
model have we have have we had another
set of questions about the sort of what
seems the mundane but what is it that
characterizes our interactions or
relationships and Freeman and co-author
really in quite encouraging questioning
and reflection and reflection
rather than Nicole of course this is
very this idea of learning is of course
a contrast to the idea that they do the
MBA and then you go and apply it for 20
years it's it's a bit of a caricature I
realize but it's certainly very far away
from that transactional leadership also
very important because organizations if
they're told something there's a new
vision where do we fit what do we do
motivate us realign resources maybe they
need to be structure structural changes
within companies new ways of new things
to monitor new ways of monitoring so
again the transactional role is very
important being able to align resources
with new tasks in order to realize a
vision and so this combination of a sort
of will for transformation and a
capacity for transactions is needs to go
together and this as the same may seem
like a contradiction interestingly it
was said that to Roosevelt combined
unqualified an unprecedented leadership
with being a broker and I must say I
found in my study a fetcher that in the
cases where she was successful which
certainly wasn't always she did have
this sort of combination of high
political will and a high policy
capacity and I'm ability to understand
causal relationships and apply solutions
there both of them appear transactional
and transformational need to appear to
the needs learning from others and I
think again this is this idea of engaged
learning an engaged leadership can't be
stressed enough erin ville dowse key who
was a famous name for some of the
political scientists wrote in not so
well-read book about Moses and he came
up with this interesting story of about
Moses that he's actually have an idea of
him leading at the front the staff but
will doubt his interpretation that
there's actually this very much also
listening being very aware of the peat
the children of Israel people of Israel
and so that his leadership was very
engaged with followership I recently
read an accounts of Winston Churchill's
wartime speeches and it turned out that
he had spies in the country or people
reporting to him about how a British
folks were feeling and that his speeches
were written in this context rather than
just from his own sense of mission to
save to save Britain than Europe
learning from critics and crises again
my friend Mark moody Stewart very much
talks about this listening to his
critics rather than denying what they
have to say would be his mode this is
from a leadership scholar Bennis create
a culture of candor to enable learning
from colleagues and marco moody Stewart
would say you need to create a a
family-like commitment for appropriate
to appropriate behaviors a family-like
commitment to appropriate behaviors
served in a family you can take off your
daughter father granny for not complying
with those appropriate behaviors and so
again leadership is very much engaged
and very open so where do these
qualities come from well there is a
psychological literature and again the
research i've seen on csr and leadership
tends to endorse these sorts of
characteristics on bullet point one
empathy curiosity courage and humility
but I think some of the one of the other
interesting things is well how then are
is leadership formed from those
predisposing factors and the
sociological in particular and I've
always been very struck by a study which
was published in the 1980s
1983 by Jonathan Boswell who'd have did
a very close business history looking at
what he called the social control of
business in United Kingdom between the
1980s and 1939
and in the cases of the companies which
he described or defined as more socially
responsible and more subject if you like
to social control he talked about these
leaders as immersed in their society as
he
in the communities immersed in politics
immersed in their churches and he
contrasted these with business leaders
who one way or another were quite
isolated either from choice of where
they lived or simply abstaining from the
the chewing and throwing of society in
the politics and the Crusades therein I
found that a terribly interesting study
for that reason so my final observation
is of course I've done the usual thing
I've talked as if we were most concerned
with the CEOs and chair people of
corporations but of course that's
manifestly not the case and quite a few
of the stories of cutting companies
which I know about I know an initiative
came from Sayer sustainability or a CSR
manager or somebody who didn't even
necessarily have that portfolio and I'd
like to end up on a Danish note lisa
Kingo who was formerly the vice
president of sustainability at novo
nordisk now actually the director of the
United Nations Global Compact she was an
intern from I think CBS at turnover
Nordisk and started asking questions
never Nordisk was being criticized at
the time well why don't we talk to the
organizations that are criticizing us
she said and luckily for her her boss
Mads office and the CEO listened and
started asking his own questions and of
course Nova Nordisk is regularly rated
among the world's most responsible
companies so the Blessed Internet can
also play a role well that's my lot but
I'm really interested in how how do you
think about these things what sense my
account makes to you
it could go to my questions if you like
is that worth doing God you are letting
you ask your own questions first yeah
yeah I think in one sense I don't know I
mean some extent I think that the
problem is so deep-seated it goes with
the extraordinary wealth that CEOs of
major companies and particularly in
countries like America and the United
Kingdom and this I'm afraid has the
effect that they physically live in
completely different places so the
problems as basic as that and they often
protect themselves from other folks it's
worth worth pointing out that mads of
Larssen who is the CEO or former CEO in
question were later became the chairman
of LIGO company you'll have heard of
he's now retired but it tells me was not
boasting at all but he's in now and his
I'd say in his mid seventies and he
would tell me that Jeremy he's he's
asked him where he lives and what he
does well my best friends are still the
people I went to school with some of
whom had this is his phrase janitorial
duties and those the peps who's going to
play tennis with that day so it's it's
possible but in a sense I think in many
countries and you don't know many Asian
countries it's the same thing that the
business leaders have got separated it's
not it's not just an American or British
problem so that's that's part of the
problem so how do you how do you ask
them not to quite have so much money if
I was like big fences around their
houses and of course you remember the
case of the BP CEO in the Blue Water
Horizon disaster talking about needing
to go back to his yacht and this is
exactly what he said so I'm afraid I'm
only underlying the significance of the
question I'm not really sure how it
happens I think it's something that
those I mean in a sense the good thing
is that these leaders do have to engage
with different sorts of people they're
not just dealing with other business
people and that that's the point of my
move from the complete organization to
the part
these new modes and I guess maybe that
the people who engage with them could
somehow solicitation but that's a
challenge for me to think about
well I think but I think brokers ships
probably the only option because I think
that you know most companies are so
mobile now that it's very difficult to
constrain them and so I'm thinking
something like tack taxation so leaving
aside mining companies which immoral has
committed to I suppose you could say
that a retailer in the United States
only sells the chocolates or whatever it
is and coca-cola to American people so
they're sort of committed to being in
America so I suppose the answer is
probably it varies depending on the sort
of business and its mobility and the
threats that it can put back on a
government which is trying to broker
some higher higher level of performance
in the absence of of the sticks and of
course we've got the interesting
proposition that the president to me
taxing companies for moving offshore
which I mean that's that's an attendance
go back I take it to a hard model of
governance and I think for many it might
work for some sort of companies properly
who foon it's not necess
whether it would be effective for the
companies which are mobile I'm lesser
what what do you think
raising the water so that although slope
but in terms of total utilitarian impact
it may be a net positive because of
smore leaders have founded a chance to
be champions there's more working for
him all this world in 2016 then there's
twenty years ago I'm gonna be fired the
taxation
yeah insurance abilities once here
doctor's visits whispered
and he went out that the church when he
saw her through by their medical loss
ratio their song rest I know
just say it say the first bit again when
they well to some extent some of the
corporate governance models are in their
favor so in Denmark for example so
leaving us obviously these are welfare
societies in which they're operating and
tend to be quite a gala terian but for
the reason example I just gave but so if
you looked at the ownership and control
of companies like Carlsberg League o V
looks supports me Novo Nordisk you'll
find that the power actually is in a
foundation the foundation not all
foundations are good of course but the
foundations tend to reflect some social
commitment of founding the founders of
the company so never Nordisk actually
they were pharmacists who wanted to use
business to spread the pharmaceuticals
that they made so what happens is that
they I they tend to have majority
shareholding or if they don't have
majority shareholding they had their the
their shares are worth twice as much as
those traded on the open market so they
were all ok this could seem like a
recipe for cronyism often there's that
there's still a high proportion of
families involved in running the family
the founding families involved in
running those
foundations but mercifully I don't see
much of that and they the foundations
are devoted to social causes so in a
sense for happy reasons and maybe foot
and only fortuitous but the corporate
governance design has enabled social
purpose to be at the core of the
business their business is about is run
was owned and controlled by an entity
which is for some social purpose social
and environmental improvement disease is
usually it and often scholarship
heaven forfend and so those those are
fairly struck that's a fairly structural
feature and as and as a result of course
see CEOs aren't as well paid CEOs are
more loyal to their companies there
isn't a market and they're not outbid
they don't necessarily want an extra
half a million they don't get it anyway
that a Danish probably the leading
Danish CEOs probably paid ten percent of
their counterparts in America so there's
a some governance to it which actually
does reflect obviously regulation around
tax tax incentives and so forth
and much like there's tax incentives for
social responsibility in this in this
country but they're just different ones
and there's a culture that goes with it
in the Danish case doesn't mean to say
that there aren't hard-nosed business
people who don't do count they obviously
do but those those are the factors I
would point to as being significant and
but I think also that's again to take a
company like novo nordisk they see their
CSR or sustainability's they now call it
as very much part of their main business
so when they go to China in in a sense
then their model which is a very
expansive health service model rather
than simply selling the drugs is what
they see at the forefront because
actually their drugs are more expensive
than a lot of the competitors so they've
got to persuade edge Chinese medical
authorities and Chinese hospitals that
it's worth buying novo nordisk because
they get
a sort of social service along with it
often in partnership with the Chinese
and professionals in fact actually
invariably in partnership with Chinese
professionals so I saw this one first
power breach and impacts the mobility
especially movie converter days later
something Kimbrough and also be for
others kana are although most of them
the biggest are importing hundreds early
so we work with college to see how how
banner to leverage the buying how as sue
introducing the sinners are to the
business and how trying to encourage
them to implement implement in
tossing those cameras obviously this
company's also
[Music]
yeah yeah it's difficult to prove almost
anywhere but of course cost savings are
the obvious one with recycling water or
heat or whatever and I think Walmart's
the Walmart story is that they they
saved an awful lot of money in a very
short space of time I spoke to a
consultant to the British variant of
Walmart his name now escapes me and the
engineers just said well why on earth
didn't you ask us before of course we
could do this and we'll save lot
somebody pairi recycling water off the
top of warehouses and so forth I think
the the so that's one that's that's the
easy one and the exhale spreadsheets can
be deployed and to persuade the CEOs I
think on some of the other ones it is
harder and quite often creating new
markets is expensive not launching new
products Ben and I were talking about
Ford's effort so green cars 10 or 15
years ago which came to naught because
there wasn't a market for them anyway
and think things may have changed
changed now but as I say note Novo
Nordisk would in terms of their policies
in China they would say what what else
can we do because we are
expensive our labor tends to be more
expensive than than most some would see
it as defensive some see it as
aggressive but it's very hard to sort of
actually detail this but on you know
take a company like the body shop in the
end their business wasn't so well-run
and they got taken over by L'Oreal I
think it was but you'd have to say that
this was a burgeoning success on a very
unlikely proposition you know against
animal testing and in favor of paying
third-world suppliers more money and and
it did become a burgeoning success but
of course there's quite a literature on
the business case for CSR I don't
understand quite a lot of it I will
confess but but I think the meta
analyses of these studies tend to say on
balance it's worth what all things being
equal their marginal benefits for doing
so but obviously that's a bundling a
huge range of cases types of investment
motivation and calculations on payoff I
mean like in the as I understood the
Chinese case I mean the government was
very keen to encourage exporting
companies about 10 years ago to improve
their CSR because they were anxious
about the evaluation of some of the
characteristics of the products in
Western markets whether that's still a
powerful driver I don't know and of
course the Shanghai Stock Exchange has
introduced some CSR criteria for listed
companies again the details I've
slightly forgotten but again the recent
work I read was that actually now
Chinese consumers and society has been
more expressive on any desire for
companies to take more responsibility I
don't know how that how you read that
yeah yeah what about pollute pollution
and things like this
okay then you've got to go in
[Music]
[Music]
so are you are you saying that because
the corporation's focus on the compact
instead of these yeah so yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and that's often the first
move and and so be it and a lot of
companies actually join the global
compact because at one point or another
it does look handy to take that
particular box but I've actually
supervised the study of the the turnover
of un un GC membership is staggering and
it's mainly because companies don't read
don't do their report every 18 months
and you only have to really write a
couple of sides and get somebody
important to sign off and Bob should be
your uncle but they don't they don't do
that which may give a sense of the
gravity with which they hold that
particular responsibility having said
that you know it's a it's yeah it does
different things and it's I think it's
created within Nations
national groups who then do more serious
work and those those who are more
committed but of course quite often the
purpose of joining that summon
initiatives is simply to tick the box
and move on and I'm afraid that's that's
what goes with things which are stents
ibly look good because sign up to them
claim that they're doing them so I think
to some extent it's a it's a reflection
of the merit of the project but sadly
the corollary is it doesn't always make
a difference to the social problem
intended and I think that yeah leaders
need will be asked to be more specific
about what's what's the intended bit
outcome of this and I think probably
they want to because the hard-nosed ones
are also want to have some sense of
value for money even if they don't want
to necessarily show profit line they
might want to show that problems
improved and they're a big number of
initiatives where companies try to best
reevaluate their impact but a bit like
the impact of academic research it's a
tricky one well I think I it's okay with
the audience I'll give myself the last
question and I'd love to have the those
who are studying these issues of
corporate sustainability and leadership
talked afterwards with me and with
Jeremy and with the rest of the group
about your thoughts on the question that
I'm about to ask so what I see out there
is a sort of disenchantment with
business and a lot of the writers who
are trying to find see us our
alternatives discuss it you know the
head of Whole Foods talks about
conscious capitalism we can't just be
Marauders about capitalism and Porter
and Kramer cited as a reason why their
form of CSR should come forward as
creating shared value and I wonder if
it's sort of discomfort with business
which clearly has a lot to do with
salaries and so forth you've already
addressed that but it seems like there's
an underlying skepticism of leadership
itself you know what do you know this is
the internet age I can
my own blog I can live in my own media
universe and I'm wondering if you're
seeing that we're certainly seeing the
brexit s-- and so forth that are
rejections of some sorts of leadership
acceptances of others perhaps and so I
just wanted a few comment on that
question about just the underlying
notion that maybe its leadership itself
that people are resisting hmm yeah of
course Coppola and Kramer created their
own sense of crisis to justify their own
solution marvellous because I don't
think that yeah I think the idea that
shared values are going to save
capitalism will motivate people actually
but because your question really goes at
leadership of institutions more
generally not of not just a business in
institutions and I'm not sure that
business institutions can necessarily
hold themselves up as having being able
to differentiate themselves from the
pack much like some other more developed
benevolent organizations might do in a
course back to a question you asked
about whether CSR brings distinctive
leadership challenges right well I think
I'm in a sense one one of the
long-standing motivations for CSR has
been legitimacy that I think business
leaders have been aware of the sneaky
feeling that people have that this is an
opportunity for some folks to make a lot
of money inappropriately in
and uncompetitive conditions with the
advantage of laws or subsidies so I
think some extent that's been there from
the start and understandably that there
is skepticism about it and I think
you're right there however that's the
plural of plurality of the social media
and the groups that have been associated
with that and their freedom of voice
makes that yet more of a challenge for
business as well as other organizations
but to some extent that that's not so
new I mean the what would they call the
muck spreaders in the United States
around the turn of the 19th to 20th
century were raising just those issues
and amongst other things corporate
social responsibility was a response and
it might be been would just say well
that the purpose really was to make that
suspicion go away rather than to address
the issues of wealth distribution and so
forth
there are some companies which are
different and it would be nice if more
would like that I think what don't want
to take up too much time scratching my
head metaphorically that I think it's
always been there and see us as part of
dealing with that but the suspicions
will persist if companies don't
demonstrate this just about making the
legitimacy go away right well thank you
very much Jeremy if you're a very
thoughtful talking
[Applause]
[Music]